c'est l'un des aspects les plus
contestés par les partisans de donald
trump le fait que ce soit les médias qui
est annoncé la victoire de jo weiden
samedi me disent s'ils un certain nombre
de personnes se sont rassemblées dans
plusieurs villes aux états unis c'est à
la suite de projection annoncée par des
médias telles que cnn ou encore associé
ty presse à ce moment là il se base sur
le décompte en pennsylvanie où leurs
projections avancent le fait que joe
biden a une avance suffisante pour ne
plus être rattrapé par son concurrent en
donald trump faisant de lui le président
élu des etats unis
mais pour les partisans du locataire de
la maison blanche cela pose plusieurs
questions est-ce que ce résultat doit
être considéré comme officiel
alors que seuls les médias l'ont avancé
pour le moment surtout que ces médias en
question on en a souvent parlé ont dans
leur grande majorité fait campagne
contre donald trump sont-ils dès lors
les plus légitimes pour jouer les
arbitres alors que le décompte se
poursuit dans un certain nombre d'états
et que des recours ont été déposés par
l'équipe juridique de donald trump
écoutez ce qu'en pense le principal
intéressé depuis quand les minables
médias de masse des sites qui sera notre
prochain président nous avons tous
beaucoup appris au cours des deux
dernières semaines
alors il faut quand même reconnaître que
des médias tels que fox news où le new
york post plutôt acquis à la cause du
président sortant ont également annoncé
la victoire de joe biden mais cette
situation n'est pas sans rappeler celle
qui s'est déroulée en l'an 2000 lors
d'une élection qui a vu s'opposer george
w bush à al gore à l'époque un recours
dans l'état de floride avait conduit un
recomptage des bulletins il avait fallu
attendre trente six jours pour qu'un
braqueur soit désigné lors malgré la
situation pour ce mois de novembre 2020
certains dirigeants considèrent la
victoire de joe biden comme acquise
c'est le cas notamment en europe
emmanuel macron anglais la merkel ou
encore boris johnson ont d'ores et déjà
adressé leurs félicitations à l'ancien
vice président même chose en ce qui
concerne le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou d'autres dirigeants
ont eux décidé de rester un peu plus
prudent et de patienter jusqu'à
l'annoncé des résultats officiels c'est
le cas par exemple de la chine ou encore
de la russie qui préfèrent ne pas se
précipiter pour commenter des résultats
qui sont contestés par le président
sortant lui-même il
m enfin du côté du président mexicain
qui dit vouloir attendre que toutes les
questions légales soient résolus pour ne
pas faire preuve de prudence